Game, Film, Food, htclig.
Long ago, The four channels lived together
in harmony.
But then everything changed when the YouTube
algorithm attacked.
Only Matpat, master of all four theories,
could bring balance to the channels.
But when YouTube needed him most, he vanished.
But I believe that Matpat can save the world.
Hello Internet!
Welcome to Film Theory, the show that's here
to reveal your secret power: subscription bending.
Try it out.
Click the button below the video to transform
it.
Now, I don't often call a lot of things perfect.
Almost anything can be improved upon in one
way or another.
But up there with Chrono Trigger, the Lord
of the Rings, and the sweet, delicious burn
of Diet Coke, is Avatar: The Last Airbender.
If ever there was a perfect animated series,
it might just be Avatar.
In case you need a bit of a refresher.
In the world of Avatar, people live in one
of four nations, each built around one of
the four traditional elements.
You have the water tribes at the North and
South Poles, the vast earth kingdom that covers
most of the world's landmass, the industrious
and aggressive fire nation, and the elusive
flighty air nomad monks.
Some people are born with the ability to bend
one of these four elements, but only one person
can master all four of them.
That one person is known as the Avatar and
is tasked with keeping the world in balance
as the very first avatar Wan explains:
Each avatar is born into a cycle, water to
earth to fire to air, so that when the previous
avatar dies, a new one is born in the next
nation.
And over the course of the various seasons,
we watch as this exact cycle plays out.
Avatar Kyoshi from the Earth Kingdom gives
way to Roku from the Fire Nation, who then
dies and opens the door to Aang from the Air
Nomads and finally Avatar Korra from the Water Tribe.
It's a great set up that allows for stories
and characters outside of the original series
to be explored, expanding the world even further.
I mean, that's basically what happened with
the sequel series, The Legend of Korra, and
it appears to be Nickelodeon's strategy with
the franchise moving forward.
There have been multiple novels and comic
books dedicated to other avatars and supporting characters.
They've even established an entire production
studio devoted to more Avatar content.
Rumor has it that a bunch of this new stuff
is going to focus on different avatars too.
Sure you have the OGs Aang and Korra as well
as the fan favorite Kyoshi, but also the next
avatar that we haven't even met yet.
There's even a live action Netflix series
on the way.
Here's hoping it goes better than the last
one.
Anyway, in my excitement for new Avatar content,
I decided to go rewatch the series and catch
up on a bunch of the spinoff stories that
they've released over the years.
And you know what, theorists?
The more and more I look, the more and more
I realize that having an avatar sucks.
This world is so much worse because of the
avatar cycle.
When you really break down what each avatar
does during their life and how it compares
to what each avatar is supposed to be doing.
You realize that each and every one of them
has largely failed, enough so that you kind
of got to ask, is it even worth having an
avatar at all?
Hop aboard your flying bison and pour out
some cactus juice, loyal theorist.
I'm about to bend your ear over this broken,
ancient tradition.
Let's start by setting our ground rules, shall
we?
Remember, the whole thing about the Avatar
is that their main goal is to keep the world
in balance, both physically and spiritually.
What exactly that means could be up for debate.
But the way I see it, an Avatar's duties largely
break down into four main tasks: 1) helping
keep international peace between the four
nations
2) helping keep internal peace within each
of those nations.
3) Protecting innocent people and bringing
justice to the unjust.
And 4) bridging the gap between the human
world and the spirit world.
So let's just start at the beginning of our
list.
One of the main parts of an avatar's duty
is to help keep international peace between
the four nations.
And admittedly, some of them are good at it.
For instance, we see that Ang has helped to
set up an international government to help
the four nations stay at peace with each other.
But literally, from the opening seconds of
the show, we know that at least one avatar
had a major oopsie in this field.
The
whole premise of the entire franchise starts
with a giant international war, and it all
happened because of the failure of the avatars.
On one hand, we could blame Aang who ran away
from his duties, which in turn opened up a
power vacuum that allowed the 100 year war
to begin.
But he was also literally 12 years old at
the time, so it’s kind of hard to fault
him for that one.
Instead, the true failure falls to Aang's
predecessor, Avatar Roku.
Roku was childhood friends with Fire Lord
Sozin, the Fire Lord who started the war.
And what's worse, Roku knew that Sozin wanted
to conquer these other nations.
So what did Roku do to stop it?
He basically gave Sozin a slap on the wrist
and a stern talking to, by his own admission,
Roku's indecisiveness, and let's be honest,
favoritism to his friend and home nation,
was a huge weakness which ultimately led to
tons of unnecessary death.
Instead, his actions led to Sozin's betrayal,
his own death, and a war that lasted generations.
His failure led to the complete annihilation
of the Air Nation, as well as all the loss
of life that comes with a war of conquest.
It’s not exactly going to be making WatchMojo's
top ten list of moments that brought balance
to the world.
And here's the thing.
We don't have to look at Roku or Aang to see
the avatar's failures here.
In the prequel novels, we learned that Avatar
Szeto the Fire Nation Avatar before Roku was
born into a time of great strife for the nation.
And instead of working internationally, like
most other avatars, Szeto decided to focus
on the domestic politics, becoming a bureaucrat
within the fire nation to help his people.
Though he helped shepherd the Fire Nation
back to prosperity.
He did this at the expense of all the other
nations.
This eventually led to an event known as the
Platinum Affair shortly after his death, which
saw the fire nation and water tribes secretly
backing a challenger to the Earth Kingdom throne.
When this was discovered it led to all three
nations becoming incredibly isolationist.
Because of this, Szeto’s immediate successor,
the air nomad Avatar Yangchen, would look
back on Szeto's legacy as messy.
So as you can already start to see, having
one person solely responsible for policing
the entire bending world is like an impossible
task.
Time is going to be the avatar’s most limited
resource and the decisions that they make
on how to spend that time inevitably means
that they're going to have to sacrifice one
major part of their duty.
Obviously, for Szeto, focusing all of his
attention on bringing prosperity to the fire
nation meant that he let conflicts arise within
other kingdoms with the Platinum Affair.
We see a similar situation arise in the Avatar
Kyoshi books.
The Avatar before her, had a singular focus
on dealing with the spiritual duties of the role.
This meant that he neglected his responsibilities
as a politician.
His neglect of the physical world allowed
the Earth kingdom to become destabilized by
infighting and Kyoshi was basically forced
to spend her entire life cleaning up that mess.
But don't feel too bad for her.
She caused even more problems than she solved.
Case in point, Chin the Conqueror.
Now, this guy was a warlord standing up against
a corrupted king.
That said, Chin was far from a hero, as Kyoshi
herself says.
This seems like the exact sort of situation
where an avatar should stand up and help make
peace. Right?
A rebellion is threatening to destabilize
an entire kingdom and both sides are led by
awful people.
The keeper of peace and balance should probably
be looking into solving this issue.
Even Kyoshi herself says.
There's that word balance.
So what did Kyoshi do to stop Chin?
Nothing.
Literally nothing.
Chin was able to conquer almost the entire
continent.
Kyoshi only decided to step in when he showed
up at her doorstep to take over the peninsula
that she called home.
Yeah, sure, Kyoshi.
Looks like you were getting right to that.
So now that Chin is literally right in front
of her, you would think that this is a good
opportunity to try and stop his conquest and
restore balance to the Earth Kingdom.
Nope!
Kyoshi uses her power to disconnect the peninsula
from the mainland and then proceeds to yeet
it out into the middle of the ocean.
Seriously, in what's arguably the most impressive
display for an avatar is powers that we see
throughout the entire franchise.
All Kyoshi does is pull a giant: “ight,
Imma head out”.
Chin's conquest was only stopped because he
was too stubborn to get out of Kyoshi his
way, falling to his death as Kyoshi Island
was being formed.
Really Kyoshi?
Sure looks like you got some massive revisionist
history going on there because you didn't
do a gosh darn thing in the months leading
up to him coming to your peninsula.
And that philosophy runs deep in the village
that Kyoshi leaves behind.
Towards the beginning of the Last Airbender,
Team Avatar lands on Kyoshi Island, where
the guiding wisdom of all the Kyoshi stans
is.
“Yeah, it's not my problem”.
Heck, even the Earth Kingdom Capitals catchphrase
“There is no war in Ba Sing Se”, follows
the same attitude.
Ignore the problem.
Deny.
Close your eyes and it just goes away.
Admittedly, things seem to go much better
under Roku's tenure. And after Aang ends the
hundred year war, things again seem to go
smoothly.
But under Korra their civil conflict after
civil conflict.
She was Avatar during the water tribe civil
war.
Under her watch, the Red Lotus assassinates
the Earth Queen and in the aftermath Korra's
inaction due to injury and PTSD lets Kuvira
seize control of a great deal of the Earth Kingdom.
Not a great track record in a long sequence
of avatars dropping the ball.
So now let's move on to our next criteria
protecting the innocent and bringing justice
to the unjust.
This one's a bit harder to judge because we
don't see a lot of the day to day lives of
each avatar.
And while yeah, we do see some heroic moments
like Aang Fighting Yakone and Korra chasing
down bender criminals in the streets of Republic
City.
There's a rotten core here that starts to
peek through the deeper we get into the franchise.
Most of The Legend of Korra’s plot revolves
around the idea of justice and what it takes
to defend everyone.
Korra’s first major adversary Amon is the
leader of a group called the Equalists, who
are all about leveling the playing field between
benders and non benders by taking away the
ability to bend.
Sound insane?
It is.
But the movement is shown to resonate with
a lot of Republic City's citizens.
Life in the world of Avatar can be incredibly
hard for non benders, even in the new supposedly
harmonious society that Aang created.
If you're a bender, you have easy access to
jobs.
Power plants use fire benders to operate.
Trains are powered by earth benders and policemen
are almost exclusively metal benders.
Benders also have a much easier time committing
acts of violence, as we're frequently shown
groups of violent benders like the triple
threat triad, the Red Lotus.
Heck, even the Republic City Police who treat
the use of force like it's second nature.
Non benders are overlooked.
They're ignored.
They're frequently threatened.
In one particular scene, Republic City's metal
bending police force herd a group of non benders
like cattle using force to break up a nonviolent
protest.
These people are targeted because the police
force has turned off the power to their homes
and they're peacefully resisting being profiled
as members of Amon's uprising just because
they aren't benders.
A woman in the crowd makes a desperate plea
for Korra’s help, saying:
And Korra does help.
Kinda.
Unfortunately for the common people, Korra
considers the issue resolved after she outs
Amon as a bender and a fraud, effectively
derailing a movement that began and grew thanks
to a genuine concern from a huge portion of
Republic City's non bending population.
So that one doesn't look all that great for
Korra.
But when you think about it, this is Aang’s
city.
He created the system that Korra inherited.
In fact, this goes well beyond just Korra
and Aang.
The imbalance between benders and non benders
is a failure of every avatar before them who
popped up or exploited the same system.
Which brings us back to Kyoshi, who honestly
might have been the worst of the bunch.
See,Kyoshi had herself a rough childhood.
She was an orphan, working as a servant until
it was discovered that she was the avatar.
She later joined a criminal gang that was
founded by her parents.
And it's not like they suddenly stopped doing
crimes after the Avatar joined.
Nope.
They decided to involve Kyoshi in the crimes.
And that's not all, Kyoshi youthful anger
heavily informed her way of thinking.
Even after learning that she was the avatar,
her thoughts were more centered on revenge
than duty.
The Rise of Kyoshi states that quote: “Her
hunger to learn all four elements had nothing
to do with becoming a fully realized avatar.
Fire, air and water were simply more weapons
she could bring to bear on a single target.”
end quote.
And much later in her life, she was so unbothered
by taking a life that she didn't see a difference
between accidents and intentional killings.
As for protecting the innocent.
Here again, we have some problems.
In Shadow of Kyoshi, Kyoshi threatens to crush
a mother and her adult son to death with a
boulder while trying to squeeze a false confession
out of them for something they didn't do.
But her single worst decision is revealed
in the canonical flash game Escape From the
Spirit World.
It's here that Kyoshi confesses to Aang her
biggest failure.
See, one of the Earth Kings during Kyoshi's
life was incredibly unpopular.
His leadership was seen as ineffective and
corrupt, and it eventually led to a peasant
uprising against him.
During the riots, the King ordered Kyoshi
to put the uprising down, and to her credit,
she refused.
Instead, she encouraged the king to listen
to the grievances of the people and find compromise.
Seems pretty good so far, right?
But here's the thing, Kyoshi admits that she
didn't like the people standing up against
the kingdom.
In fact, throughout the whole story, Kyoshi
seems less concerned about the human rights
abuses committed by the king and more concerned
that the peasants are destroying historical
artifacts and upsetting the stability of the
monarchy.
So in exchange for the king listening to his
people and ending the riots, Kyoshi agrees
to train an elite group of earth benders for
him.
They would be, quote, “silent, precise and
feared by all”.
It was a force that would eventually be known
as the Dai Li.
Yup.
You remember those creepy secret police from
the animated series?
the ones with the rock gloves whose loyalty
could be bought and sold, and who sided with
Azula and the fire nation during the invasion
of Ba Sing Se?
They were Kyoshi's idea.
She even admits that she regrets not foreseeing
the long term consequences of giving future
Earth Kingdom monarchs access to an elite
secret police force.
But here's the thing, that move didn't make
sense even in her time period.
This king, the one that was ready to crush
his own people,
he shouldn't have had access to that secret
police force either.
Imagine what he would have had them do to
the peasants if they were around to begin with.
Then again, when you're as powerful as Kyoshi
and you treat your powers like a big ol’
hammer, I guess everything looks like a nail.
So again, for a lot of the avatars, protecting
the innocent and bringing justice to the unjust
is just a bust.
So that's three for three where a ton of avatars
fail.
But what about our fourth criteria here?
Bridging the gap and keeping the peace between
the human and spirit worlds.
This is basically THE thing that avatars are
supposed to be good at.
Surely there isn't a legacy of failure here,
too.
Well, you would think, and then you would
be wrong.
We hear in the prequel novel dedicated to
Avatar Yangchen, that when humans and spirits
came into conflict, she would strike bargains
that would get the spirits to leave humans
alone so long as they took care of the physical
world.
And of course, humans did not live up to their
end of the deal.
As a result, spirits wound up committing a
lot of violence against humans who broke their oaths.
This, in turn, created a huge mess for the
next avatar, Kuruk, to clean up.
We discover in the Kyoshi novels that Avatar
Kuruk would end up spending most of his short
life fighting the dark spirits empowered by
Yangchen’s decisions.
Finally, let's skip forward to Avatar Korra,
who might just have been the avatar to fail
the most at this one.
At the end of the Legend of Korra Season two,
Korra’s subdued by her uncle Unalaq, who’s
merged with the Dark Spirit Vaatu.
Unalaq is able to rip the Avatar spirit Raava
from Korra's body, severing her connection
to the past avatars forever, thousands of
years worth of knowledge snuffed out in an instant.
Additionally, during this battle, we witness
a world shifting event called the Harmonic
Convergence.
Basically, a portal opens between the spirit
and human worlds, allowing people and spirits
to pass freely between them.
At the end of it, Korra decides to keep the
portals to the Spirit World open, a decision
that reverses the stance of the very first
avatar and fatefully combines the human and
spirit worlds.
At first glance it seems brilliant, right?
Wouldn’t the peaceful coexistence between
humans and spirits create a more meaningful
bond between them?
Well, not necessarily.
The unforeseen consequence of these two vastly
different worlds colliding is complicated
and really doesn't scream balance.
First, the overlapping geographies of the
world create huge territory issues.
Houses in Republic City are overrun by vines
and entire city blocks are destabilized.
It doesn't matter if you're a bender or a
non bender, finding your living room destroyed
and your building about to collapse, is definitely
on the list of top five worst breakfast time surprises.
And second, harmonic convergence gives Zaheer,
one of the most dangerous warriors in the
world, the power of Airbending, which he promptly
uses to start assassinating world leaders
and throw the world out of balance.
I'm going to chalk that one up as a big oopsie
there Korra.
When you stop and look at the totality of
what we know about the Avatars, one thing
becomes clear time and time again.
This is a vicious cycle.
Every single one of these avatars dealt with
difficult issues, but their solutions just
wound up creating more problems for the immediate
successor.
Szeto focused too much on his own country.
Yangchen has to deal with and break down isolationist
policies.
Yangchen helps make peace between the four
nations, but at the cost of angering the spirits,
Well, Kuruk has to spend his life battling
dark spirits and winds up neglecting the real
world nations.
Kuruk dies early in battle with spirits, leaving
an unstable political situation.
Kyoshi creates a secret police to try and
paper over the problems of her country.
Roku shows favoritism to his home nation,
Aang has to deal with the century long war
and the death of his entire people.
All of them ignore non benders, Korra has
to deal with the fallout and the Equalists.
The Avatar cycle is a cycle of violence.
It is a broken system and honestly that makes
perfect sense.
Ask yourself, why does the avatar have to
have a monopoly on balance in this world?
The very concept of the avatar is imbalanced.
At the end of the day, the avatars possess
the power of a god, literally god of light,
but they're still only humans.
Aang was a 12 year old kid faced with solving
a 100 year old war.
Kyoshi was a poor orphan.
Eventually, she's going to defend her home
so it wasn't ripped away again.
Roku was friends with Sozin.
Of course, he's going to be slow to action
and more lenient in his judgment.
One person holding that much power, that much
influence, it’s a recipe for disaster.
I feel like I've heard this somewhere before.
In the end, the really successful avatars
or maybe the least unsuccessful avatars are
the ones that don't do it alone.
Aang saves the world from Fire Lord Ozai because
he trusts his friends to help get the job done.
Sokka, Toph, Suki, Zuko and Katara are all
off playing key parts in stopping the Fire Nation.
While Aang has his rad Dragon Ball Z fight
against Ozai.
And those friends are just as essential after
the war in helping him restore balance too.
His friends helped make and keep the international
peace all in ways that Aang wouldn't be able
to do on his own.
It just goes to show that controlling all
the elements in this world is meaningless
if you don't also control the element of friendship.
But hey, if you want more Avatar: The Last
Airbender content right now, go check out
our previous theory talking about the science
of water bending.
Yeah, believe it or not but what you see Katara
and Aang doing in the series isn't that far
out of the realm of possibility.
Or if you want something a little different,
I actually teamed up with Nickelodeon themselves
and did a video breaking down whether or not
a creature as big as Appa could actually fly.
It's different, but it was a really fun collab
with the people who made this show happen
in the first place.
As always, don't forget to subscribe with
all that new Avatar content.
You know, we're going to have a ton more to
cover here on the channel.
But until then, my friends remember it's all
just a theory A FILM THEORY!
aaaaaand cut.